louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
Stephen
wake up Stephen yo fastest shot what
what's going on freak you're not gonna
make your call time what are you talking
about is this what you're looking for
these things are positively dangerous
Steve I disagree
especially when you take into account
Walters attention to safety
no first I was trying to figure out why
did Peter research I bought a book now a
book which you obviously have never read
I know everything I don't a bar okay
I'll read it I'll read your book okay
just let me out of here no no no it's
far too late for that now it's time for
you to pay your penance you pre we've
been through premium what the hell are
you talking what's going on over here
why am i strapped down Bernie whatever
it is you're thinking about you and
please don't do it please don't do it
Bernie it's time to put goal be love it
for profit health care to the test
already no oh god no Bernie please don't
do this you don't have to do this just
put the hammer down put the hammer down
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay thank you very much I'm a very
pleased to be hosting this program today
Steven Carter is Mark Levin yes on the
program later
although the DNC candidates are running
of course we have a quarter after
American Garrett what's an ass like a
half oriental Asian Gerald Morgan Jr
yeah yeah and I put the wine of the day
yes and I brought a special one for you
sir because the kind of policies that
you tend to push on us do this to
dissidents it's called it's called
blindfold they usually get shot right
after who so I just thought it was for
you that's a reasonable so I guess the
question of the day which is important
for everyone to be discussing right now
crying OH given the current state of our
of our democracy which of the 217 people
running against me should I choose okay
it's my running man you pick a horse you
tell me in that's the is it the comments
section
it's the comments yes the Canada it's
what the kids use underneath before we
get to that and my problems with all the
nominees leading the news homeland of
Urban Development HUD secretary okay
doctor I don't think that's actually the
acronym which is relevant to this it's
rather this what ben Carson was asked
about the real estate on properties
commonly referred to as Oreos
unfortunately for for the doctor he
heard Oreos as you look it up I'd also
like you to get back to me if you don't
mind to explain the disparity in REO
rates do you know what an REO is an Oreo
are not an Oreo are dr. ben Carson
subsequently asked about the effects of
real estate on foreclosures that they've
had on the African American community
Wow just because he doesn't parrot the
the leftist policies doesn't mean he's I
mean not black I mean come on that's
that's a little bit of an unfair
characterization I would say yeah we
shouldn't know what an REO was but you
know hey mom will make mumbleson he
couldn't he couldn't hear what she was
saying that's true yeah he was hungry
yeah why is it that salute evening mama
quarter for me could you don't have to
keep me you're on screen for the whole
to remain the grand times I'll have to
have a crick in my back - you lose
Patriots in the United Kingdom Patriots
they've started throwing milkshakes at
their fascist so far Nigel Nigel Faraj
Tommy Robinson and Sargon love the cat
have all been milkshake by these are
brave British victories yeah there's a
waste of a milkshake though I mean
that's what's your favorite flavor there
senator ice cream and gelato nowhere
else in there frost know Oreos at all
frosty no flavors I'm a boy vanilla man
pure pure than okay
right looks like you reckon I'm okay
consistency just yourself I prefer black
white so we'll go little [ __ ]
hoorah Wow okay absolutely warrior on a
reddit thread about accidentally giving
her father herpes
after losing his race this comes from
from the mirror that's the sexually
active girl was on holiday and used her
father's razor to touch up put down
there before going on again
yeah you never know what's gonna happen
this this story would be it would be
even funnier if it hadn't caused her
spare parents to actually split up they
actually actually got in a big fight of
this cuz you can this away that becomes
a cautionary my yeah right you can't no
one should be a force to split up and
then not be able to survive simply
because they use the Venus driven in
socialist economies don't they tend to
run out of things that are common like
razor blades so people would actually
have to share those a lot of the shy of
her Bishop lines are actually a good
thing oh they're good they not for hurry
is there not a really the will to get
you your something but I bet you don't
hear me okay so an Austrian official
warned against a cow kissing challenge
for charity the official said the
pastures are not petting zoos and
getting intimate with cows can have
serious consequences
I think allowing allowing Bernie to do
these photo shops was of that idea yes
he needs more whines red line prisoner
whiner quarter yeah but your goal is to
take it away sooo cool but it's a signal
[Music]
now what switching to holiday because
what never like that program yes yeah
the talented and brave a Mohammed
whatever hope to Instagram this week to
stick it to the patriarchy and show the
world what new motherhood is actually
like by snapping a picture with her bra
like she can we you want to see that
again
Wow actually I never I never wanna have
cookies and poke again that's the mental
tie that I have to it and by the way why
is this considered brave why is it brave
for her to do that post a picture that a
lot of women are doing these things I
assume there's a percentage of technical
mishap so it can happen with these shoes
by the way I hope he doesn't anticipate
passing the ball okay oh my gosh look
it's just not it's not a break she's not
funny and it's not brave both of those
things are wrong hi sorry I'm sorry
Alabama Public Television they refused
to air the gay wedding up is so good of
the children's program author fantastic
are they here to rerun have you followed
yeah yeah yeah instead they aired a
rerun in Alabama of the high highly
publicized in place sorry of the I'm not
used to he was in prompt no come the
horn oh I'm sorry yeah as a human being
really they ran a rerun instead of
private Brendan instead of a highly
publicized as you know mr. Ratburn yes
and the special someone I saw one vessel
someone the episode
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
how do you feel about that running mate
are we talking about yeah yeah you know
actually it's my god do you have our
preferences yourself and people who are
watching in the comment section look let
us know who you think is the most viable
or candidate
I'll let you catch me well no but you
start a little bit you know I think the
best candidates are gonna have to be the
ones that are millionaires so that
that's why I love you right at the top
of the list there senator if you were
good right at a best-selling book as
well rather than playing that third da
fiddle on our third string late-night
program for a while maybe we could be
millionaires do you have a booty gig I
think is for name alone okay because
it's hilarious almost 20 Democratic and
I'm running at this point and I'm going
to go through reasons for why you
shouldn't vote for any of them okay Oh
booty kick ah first he served in the
military
uh-huh mayor of a small town Indiana but
his greatest ik qualification of which
he lets you know constantly certain
plane he plenty of indications by the
time I was fifteen or so that I could
point back into like yep Dennis this
kids gay when I came out Mike Pence was
the governor of Indiana when I joined
the military Don't Ask Don't Tell was
still the law of the land
oh boy well I look through that little
screen on my phone and I saw this smile
this guy and I clicked the button on the
right I have the most important thing in
my life my marriage to chasten
right that's faith if that's your only
qualification right is your sex your
reference or your gender oh my gosh yeah
that's the way an aggressive prosecutor
no she defended you probably could have
felt oriental the three strike law in
California she upheld I believe was the
only state that impose life sentences
for a third strike that could be even
any any minor felony oh yeah absolutely
the streets in San Francisco she's
thrown you in the clink well reasonable
doing that yeah just San Francisco
California and it seems here like that
the that you're these are almost like
Republican viewpoints it's really
interesting to hear she said like you're
you're bringing up very good reasons why
so far that these people shouldn't be
considered a break
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's a reasonable charge oh man
where are you 65 early 90s smoke the pot
too right I think we all know that
there's no way you're going to be the
man you are today without smoking pot I
never oh really
only meth Oh
Bernie Sanders handler call me claiming
favorite artists including Marlee okay
do you have a favorite band or a
favorite musician I'd say one of my
favorites is Bob Marley good choice
that's look kind of bad when you're
running for president man all right
let's run it on the backs of the
prisoners oh he wants them to vote yes
oh that's right yeah that's right what
do you think about that lawyer uh you
know I think it's somewhat ironic that a
lot of the folks we put into prison she
now wants to vote yeah but you like that
right it's inconsistent four of my
colleagues yeah when I won't speak badly
of any of them but that might send the
vote to you you never know because I'm
going to vote for her kidney strand in
there okay Nesbitt Warren is next in the
list no this is the broad who recently
called for a boycott and Fox News is
calling it a hate for profit Network
yeah now this is important to note the
differences this stands in stark
contrast to the Fox News town halls in
which me and my colleague Pete Beauty
get there you go yeah
correct but giggle in order to reach so
you don't like her isn't running me I
appreciate that you used Pocahontas
though that at least shows that she's
faking this this supposed what 1/1000
[Applause]
you chump it over to our side here a
little bit I like she would qualify to
get into your wife's old University with
that a diversity number that happens for
relevancy he's just plain old grabbing
ass into the US Senate as well from
uncomfortable to plain awkward as Biden
up down slightly all is so creepy to
whisper in Carter's hear say it calls
for some sort of universal health care
there were something like Medicare for
all from some of the other people
running all right IIIi think they're
they're well intended I think that mean
it is and it's not but here's the deal
right now you have sixteen you have this
overwhelming number of employers for a
pain in the health care plan why let
them off the hook all of a sudden they
don't have to pay anything what happens
then - this whole thing about profit and
the rest it should be part of the
compensation if you have could bankrupt
the system sir I don't we can support I
appreciate your care for the victims of
Biden yeah it's just storming the heart
yes but but also the mental health care
services that you're championing you
should probably avail yourself of those
services as well sir okay well maybe
maybe better health care would be better
maybe I'm not sure they're actually
effective we need real doctors here
well I can't sit on the couch for long
because my back is creaky oh yes
yes those are
okay girlfriend will get pneumonia by
the way the notification bell ah and
join us let my club but don't actually
do it
no yeah pay the money yeah absolutely do
sure do it yeah do it I tuned Islam is
Corey are Corey book oh I do while being
fair is a grandstanding no yes oh okay
yeah this neck of an actual marionette
couldn't be yep very good couldn't be he
couldn't be more cringing right yeah ah
then well perhaps this is a prime
example when he made this claim while
kissing genuinely great extended yeah
I'm going to release the email about
racial profiling and I understand that
that the penalty comes with potential
I'll sting from the Senate and if
Senator Cornyn believes that I said it
was III
openly invite leasing that email right
now this is about the closest I'll
probably ever have in my life to an
[Laughter]
that's actually probably true
oh my gosh that by the way that was one
of the worst moments of Cory Booker's
career he got outed like the next day
like hey this information sorry publicly
yeah oriental is that in fact was he
committing some act of bravery or was
that in fact already the rules that was
already released I mean I think it is it
does show a lot of courage to openly lie
in grandstand spin I mean I'm not
willing to do it so the lying
swag Rosario when she told you that's
gotta hurt this guy this guy yo Joe
thinks margaritas are made with five no
death penalty
margarita this fruit and there is ice
and there is oh my gosh okay I get it
times I I kind of thought that you would
be for this I thought margaritas having
vodka because of your love for Russia
they produce touch your body a lot of
luck I thought that that would be cool
with you I am a fan of the Soviet Union
but Jimmy Buffett margaritas not
Margaritaville yeah
totally different hearing it if you
can't hear me machines from a Russian
20% off coupon then it's worth Dyson
from you [ __ ] these kitties critiques
those seem a little bit self-serving
this kind of leaves us with one person
yeah I merrily to to vote for on that
side is that is the reason FairPoint and
I believe we'll talk about it before I
here ah
Orientals closing thoughts with Mark
Levin
[Music]
nice I'm still here it's very important
if you want me to live to join my club
and lattimer's better that slice my club
it's only 99 dollars annually 69 for
students veterans or active military and
you can access the entire blaze catalog
this hand edged mud then I can't reach
right now
explosive join my club
no now take it off the screen
don't do it stop stop
[Music]
look let's turn to one part of this that
I find most interesting because whenever
you have an organization like this or
like I'm thinking of other movements
like blogs it and things like this
[Music]
[Music]
okay so uh I had some time to calm down
yeah I got a little bit heated before
the show you did it's okay for on the
first break it's true it's true talk
about our next guest I have right here I
have in front of me he I don't watch his
program mm-hmm full disclosure but it's
on now Fox News blaze TV Levin TV and
his new book is unfreedom
okay of the puss or mark mr. Levin thank
thank you for coming on the program it
is a great honor kind of thank you
it's thank you I appreciate it uh let me
ask you your book mark unfreedom of of
the press oh yes can you explain it for
people notably this audience who has not
read it yes well you're very good by the
way
I think the problem we have here in our
country is we do not have a free press
we have a media a media that likes
people like you a media that's made of a
people like you a media that basically
advances a social activism progressivism
Democrat Party agenda where you have
about 80% of the Republicans who reject
it about 80% of the Democrats who love
it when you look at your favorite
network CNN and MSNBC or your favorite
newspapers Pravda I mean the New York
Times and The Washington Post you can
see that again it is loaded with people
who are pushing your opinion rather than
news for a moment mark I want to be
clear you've sort of alluded that the
American press has gone from being this
perhaps great bastion of objective
journalism to effectively degenerating
into more of a standardless profession
do I have that approximately correct you
do have it approximately correct and
basically me no I'm just a little part
of the media but I'm not part of the
news media that's for sure but
mark mark yeah you do have three shows
to your name you have a lot of programs
out there in the media
Bernie let me tell you something I've
actually to come on every one of them
and you won't come on any of my shows
why is that
listen Vermont is a very diverse a busy
steak and oh yeah I have I can't always
be appearing on every shoulder that's
Bob but I will make it a point after
this program to appear yeah we'd love to
have you on because I want to dig into
your philosophy you know Marxism and
Hegel ISM and Rousseau ISM and
hemorrhoid ISM the whole thing no mock
mock that is a misrepresentation of what
I believe okay
I do not want the United States to be
like Venezuela which people have said
that's not true that's not true I want a
better care for all and a system like
you would see in Catalonia in the 1930s
which was very successful mark so let's
not do the misrepresenting of each
other's voices yeah
yeah but it is your presupposition that
the media is far-left correct when you
yourself have a show on fox news yeah
okay that's like Israel in the middle of
the Middle East you know the fact is
that the rest of the Middle East would
be like the American media you know you
look at the New York Times The New York
Times lied about the Holocaust I'd say
that's pretty bad Bernie and the New
York Times lied about the wiping out of
10 million Ukrainians by Stalin I'd say
that was pretty bad too and they call
themselves the paper of record and and
all the news that's fit to print i i'd i
just don't buy we go into that that is
that is bombastic the voice of you and
that is that is untrue mark well I don't
know many scholars have pointed it out I
just decided to make it available to the
mass majority of the American people
that the New York Times pushed the
Holocaust to its back pages where I come
from that's pretty bad also they did the
same thing with this Lord of the
Ukrainians as I point out but he we even
have this Russia collusion thing you're
familiar with Russia
you know us spent your honeymoon in
Moscow you know better than I do
that's true and that went on I had a one
I had a wonderful experience I I do not
shy away from it I've been very open
about this Oh Marsha has been a very
beautiful but please did I think that of
course president Rocas colluded with and
bring me to my next point
mark mark we're getting off stop where
do you yes lineup on impeachment I
believe that we should impeach Nancy
Pelosi and maybe Chuck Schumer although
they're not subject to impede maybe
expel them I reject impeachment of the
president United States he's a victim
he's police state tactics out of the FBI
in the Department of Justice there was
already criminal investigation we have
Jerry Nadler you know Jerry you guys
used to hang around in the same
basements and so forth you got guys like
Jerry Nadler and other leftists mostly
out of New York and San Francisco LA and
so forth and they're trying to topple
this presidency and disenfranchise 63
million people who voted for this
president they put out these phony
subpoenas for his personal records
look the presidents of billionaire
you're a multimillionaire Nancy Pelosi
is worth tens of millions of dollars so
maybe everybody leads their tax perhaps
if you write a New York Times
best-selling book you could be a
multi-millionaire - okay it's not fair
character Danny no I'm not
muck muck there's no need for personal
insults I've written best-selling books
yes you have not everybody has done
anything and I have paid my fair share
at which point who doesn't deserve a
third lake house okay so yourself it
sounds to me like you're doing quite a
bit of herb what about us um mark what
about Nancy Butchie what about Chuck
Schumer what about the man in office who
is vulgar dangerous and his deregulated
an economy that is frankly what's the
middle class look I don't mind what
about ISM by the way it's the one is am
I like you know beats Marxism and
socialism anyway what do I think about
the president actually the middle class
has expanded that there is job creation
called capitalism tax cuts reducing
government reducing regulations that's
why we have such great wealth in this
country and that's why we have such
great growth that's why we the biggest
middle class of any society on the face
of the earth that's why you can go into
a supermarket and purchase virtually
anything you want we live like kings and
queens compared to 200 years ago
unlike your Venezuela or Cuba or all the
other experiments that take place and
like Vermont that's true let's do we do
we have in Vermont with a more
socialized system and we don't leave
anybody left behind
Marc but let me ask you final question
we do have to get going
the book is unfreedom of the press from
a man who hosts for programs in front so
Marc which yes Democrat currently
running do you think has in your
estimation okay it's Jim of beating mr.
Trump I think John Hickenlooper I think
that's his name I I think John
Hickenlooper or Hickenlooper or whatever
his name is I think he has the best
chance I think that looks pretty good on
a bumper sticker or maybe Andrew yang I
understand Andrew yang is running for
president of this country so I'd put my
money on those two okay
perhaps I should rephrase which senior
citizen who happens to be a Democratic
candidate do you believe would most
likely I'd say Elizabeth Warren she
looks a little long in the tooth I
suspect she might have a shot at Joe
Biden
bloke let's move on to the clothes wet
clothes
[Music]
hi I'm Bernie Sanders and I'm the only
member of the DNC from the last election
cycle to not get an F from the NRA I got
a d-minus so you know my opinion matters
whathe I don't know much about firearms
but I hear good things this so called
bird doesn't fly and is protected by the
US government no one knew why until now
since the dawn of time the ground owl
has been there for every tragedy
Society has ever known had the ear of
kings and leaders throughout the world
the ground owl burrowed its way into
every aspect of our culture and
influenced even the most prestigious
influencers even Washington DC itself
was designed to pay homage to this vile
creature and this is only the beginning
join us on crowded conspiracies as we
finally expose the ground owl
[Music]
[Music]
no now take it off the screen don't stop
[Music]
[Music]
so ah I have to say that I am NOT a huge
fan of the program
but I kind of I appreciate it thanks for
coming out I think I but I mean it
wasn't great but good job so I do want
to talk in this life segment I get asked
this a lot on the campaign trail a
question for many American citizens from
the heart and I'd like to take the
opportunity to answer this for all
Americans
not just the ones who will vote for me
but for all American
ah we find ourselves in tough times
unemployment in this country is almost
3.9 percent average individual wages
have slowed the less than five and a
half percent growth year over year sure
there's a job surplus but for many of
you these are not the jobs you want it
well the tax break across the board has
put more money in most people's pockets
yeah for sure it is disproportionately
put more money in the pockets of the
wealthiest 10% okay and this is led to
many people to feel that the American
Dream is dead that the lifestyle your
parents maybe enjoyed good it's out of
reach for many of them and I get that
said if the American Dream is dead and
as it pertains to the the question of
any meaningful change to reverse course
many people who talk to me in the
connect feel you feel hopeless aren't
most of us the 10% nope no that's the
carrot that's dangling like a rabbit on
the trip if
she ever seen rabbits on the trip yeah
what do we going around and but there's
no carrot so I want to take this
opportunity for many of you who feel
hopeless to tell you that um as a public
figure and it's one who wants to inspire
many of you to to understand what's
going on in our country it's hopeless
for me there's no way you can make it in
this country none of those things are
possible
what other choice do you have
do it on your own and pull yourself up
by your bootstraps you son of a [ __ ]
you delusional son of a bleep ho ass
boots with straps anymore yo Jamie you
can't make it in America without me
that's just what the Koch brothers want
you to think I'll fade out from
somewhere there with the music
[Music]